عقار اوزمبك وهو علاج لمرض السكري يجتاح
العالم كدواء سحري للرشاقه على مواقع
التواصل اكثر
274 مليون او 74 مليون مشاهده حصل عليها
هاشتاق اوزانبك الذي اصبح الاكثر شهره بين
الباحثين عن الرشاقه
وارتفع طلب على العقار الطبيه وزمبك خلال
الاشهر الماضيه ليصل الى 57 في المئه في
نهايه 20 22 لكن الامر كان كارثيا على
مرضى السكري الذين اصبحوا يعانون من نقص
حاد في جميع انحاء العالم ويعمل اوزمبك هو
الاسم التجاري الدواء من خلال محاكاه
هرمون منظم الشهيه لخلط الشعور بالامتلاء
وهو الامر الذي يستهدفه الباحثون عن جسم
متناسق باسرع وقت ممكن
مزيد مع لميس
الاوزنبيك هو عقار طبي يساعد على زياده
افراز الانسولين ومن ثم زياده تمثيل السكر
ويؤخذ شكل الحقن او الاقراص الفمويه اثروه
يمتد لفتره طويله لدى المستخدمين خصوصا
الذين يعانون من مرض السكري بدرجاته
المتقدمه يعمل اوزومبيك على ابطاء عمليه
انتقال الطعام من المعده للامعاء اضافه
لابطاء امتصاص الطعام والمواد المغذيه من
قبل الامعاء ما يساعد في منح احساسا
بالشبع يمتاز لوزنبك بدوره الكبير في
خساره الوزن وسهولته مقارنه بالتقنيات
الجراحيه وحتى غير الجراحيه لمعالجه
السمنه فالمريض يمكن ان يعطيها لنفسه مثلا
لكن لها بعض الاثار الجانبيه مثل الامساك
وصعوبات في الهضم
على كل من جده ينورنا استشاري الامراض
المعديه والباطنيه الدكتور نزار بهابريس
يسعد صباحك اليوم ودوم يا دكتور اهلا بك
صباحكم اجمل صباح صباح جميل على كل
المشاهدين الدكتور انت عندك تجربه شخصيه
مع التنحيف مع خساره الوزن ما رايك بهذا
العقار الذي يجتاح العالم اليوم لمعالجه
داء السكري وهو اليوم يستخدم للتنحيف
اول حاجه نبقى ننكد عليها انه اغلب
المشاهدين بما فيهم اللي مثلا غالبيه اللي
موجودين في الاستوديو
اغلبهم يبوا ينحف دائما الناس كذا في
عندها احساس بانهم يا ريت انهم ينزلوا كم
كيلو هذا شيء موجود في كل العالم
في ناس قله راضيين
بيقدموا البرنامج اكيد ما يبغى لهم
طيب لكن بخلاف اي شيء
حقيقه انا صحيح تجربتي الحمد لله خسرت 66
كيلو
تقريبا نصف اوت
فبالتالي على مدار سنه وسبع شهور بني ادم
ريح نص البني ادم انت جربت الحقنه دكتور
استعملتها استعملت كل الانواع انا انا
بينهم انا شخصيا اعالج مرضيه في العياده
بانه في البدايه لازم يجربوا اليوميه
علشانها احيانا لما الاوزنتيك تستخدم
وتيجي الاعراض الجانبيه شديده تكرهها
الانسان في اكتئاب وامساك واللي يجي لهم
غثيان يستمر طوال الاسبوع فانا خليهم
يبتدوا باليوميه طيب
يعني كثير في عنا اسئله حول هذا الموضوع
يعني موضوع لافت وبهم العالم
يعني انت لما فكرت تاخده كان عندك وزن
زائد هل اي شخص بيقدر ياخذه يعني انا مثلا
حابه انزل كم من كيلو بقدر اروح على
الصيدليه وابلش بهذا الكورس طبيعي
والله شوفي انا رحت لطبيبه رحت لطبيبه
استشاريه غدد صناعه علشان ابدا صحيح انا
استشاري بعضكم ولحين انا بعالج بيه المرضى
لكن حقيقه اول ما رحت لازم اروح للطبيب
لازم تروح للطبيب علشان مو كل شيء انت
تقدر توزنه لحالك
اوكي رقم اثنين انا لازم ااكد لكل واحد
يشوفني انه انا ابتدات بالرياضه
علشان كنت ابغى اتنفس
وكنت الرياضه هي الاساس الاول عشان اخسر
وزني
طيب يعني
حقنه اوزنبك مع نظام غذائي صحي ومع رياضه
طيب البعض يحذر من مضاعفات تؤثر على الجسم
كتاثيرها على الكبد مثلا هذه الفعل لديها
مضاعفات لابد الخوف منها طيب في بعض
الاشياء قيلت غير صحيحه رقم واحد انها
الابر اللي يستخدموها تجيب السكر غير صحيح
رقم اثنين قيل انها تزود من سرطان الغده
الدرقيه وهذا اثبت في الفئران في بدايه
التجارب ولم يثبت على الانسان
نظرا لان الغده الدرقيه حدث الانسان ما
فيها حتى الحساسات اللي يجي عليها الدواء
رقم ثلاثه انه الناس اللي يستعملوها يرجع
وزنهم اضعاف اللي خسران غير صحيح هو انت
ترجع لاعاداتك القديمه تقوم انت ترجع صحيح
الناس بعد ما تركوها رجعوا تقريبا 15% اذا
ما حافظوا على النظام الغذائي والرياضه
رياضه انت تتريب عشان تحرق عشان تقدر تاكل
اذا ما غيرت من اسلوب فكرك ما تنفعك الابر
حتنزل وترجع تطلع بس اسمع حتى العمليات
تنزل
هي هل فعلا انه مش انه بتنزل وزن بتتحكم
بعمليات الايض هي فقط بتقلل شهيه الشخص
للسكر
طيب صحيح طيب انا بسالك هم ما يقولوا في
الابحاث انه الابر اليوميه تنزل تقريبا
سبعه ثمانيه في الميه من الوزن الثاني 15
الى 22% طيب والجديده طيب هذولا انا الان
66 تقريبا يعني انا تقريبا نزلت 50% كيف
تيسير هو يعتمد على كميه انت قديش مستعد
انك انت تبذل وقت
التزام نظام غذائي ورياضه الرياضه علشان
تحرق مو الرياضه اللي هو انت تنزل تمشي
حوالين البيت كذا وتشعر بس بالدف انك انت
سويت حاجه انت ما عرقت ما تعبت ما ارتفعت
نبضات قلبك ما سويت اي حد ما تخسر انت
الخساره الحقيقي تعرف انا انا ابغى اقول
لك انا ماني طبيب انا ماني طبيب انا
اعتبريني مجرب خلاص انا اقدر اقول لكم
ايمان كامل بتجربه انه الابر المساعده
الاول لك انك تخليك محترم في الاكل يعني
انت في الاكل اللي انت تحبه وتقول انا راح
اكل لقمه وراح اوقف مو انك ما تقدر تاكل
زياده لا تقدر لو تبغى
تاكل بس لو كان مخك قرر انه يتغير في
الفكر والله لو اكلت لما تعرفي دائما مهمه
يقولوا دائما في التغذيه يقولوا لقمه زي
انت قول لي مخك لقمه زي عشره لقم انت لو
اكلت لقمه واحده من التشيز كيك كانك اكلت
العشره هي نفس الطعم وهم يحاولوا يقنعونا
بهذا صحيح الابر تساعدك على انك تصير زي
كذا
متوفره للجميع بنقدر نشتريها الحقيقه انها
انها غاليه في بعض الدول مختلفه اسعارها
في بعض الدول والحقيقه عليها اجتياح مره
كبير نظرا لانه زي ما قلت لكم نزول الوزن
حاجه يبغاها كثير من البشر جدا شكرا
شكرا كثير يا دكتور نزار بهبري من جده
استشاري الامراض المعديه والباطنيه شكرا
شكرا دكتور شكرا